this is the man charged with the killing
of PC Andrew Harper 20 year old Jane
Foster was led into reading Magistrates
Court via an underground car park he's
also accused of stealing a quad bike
along with persons unknown there are a
large number of officers stationed
inside and outside the court buildings
PC Harper was responding to reports of a
burglary when he was dragged underneath
the wheels of a vehicle and died from
multiple injuries nine other men and
boys who were arrested and questioned
have been bailed until next month in a
hearing lasting just a couple of minutes
Jed's Alexander foster spoke only to
confirm his full name his age and his
address the courtroom was packed
not just with journalists but also
relatives and friends of the defendants
and also family of PC Harper the
defendant solicitor said that his
clients denied any involvement in the
murder
standing alongside Jed Foster's mother
Joe who was clutching a teddy bear
throughout the hearing he repeated the
comments outside the court on behalf of
him and his family he emphatically
denies any responsibility or involvement
in the horrific murder of PC Andrew
Harper we urged the police to follow
every single line of inquiry to prove
who is responsible and to ensure that
there is justice in this case we also
urge any member of the public who has
information however difficult it is for
them to come forward and TVA's with the
police five days on from the incident
which led to his death there's still an
outpouring of public sympathy for the
policeman and his widow Lissy as well as
for his wider family some of whom
attended today's proceedings the blanket
of bouquets left at the scene grows
larger by the hour
and more than two hundred thousand
pounds is being donated to a fundraising
appeal set up by Thames Valley Police
Federation Jed foster from Berfield near
Redding was remanded in custody and is
due to make his next appearance at
Redding Crown Court tomorrow morning
his mother and other family members left
court without saying anything to
reporters the solicitor representing
them asked for them to be left alone
saying the situation is very stressful
in woods Sky News reading